there are dumb questions there are
questions that waste your time and my
time and everybody else's time and I've
never had a job in my life that I was
better than I was always just lucky to
have a job being able to create an
impulse within a consumer to do
something is in art form if you want to
be Mark Zuckerberg the best you're ever
going to be a second place because Mark
Zuckerberg will always be a better Mark
Zuckerberg than you he's an American
actor and investor he began his career
as a model and started acting as Michael
Kelso on the Fox sitcom that 70s show in
2004 he starred in the psychological
film the butterfly effect and gave even
more attention he's Ashton Kutcher and
here is my take on his top ten rules for
success rule number ten is my personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end for some special
bonus clips and as always if he says
something that really resonates with you
make sure to put it in the comments and
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired as well
there are dumb questions there are
questions that waste your time and my
time and everybody else's time I started
thinking what is a great question what
constitutes an exceptional question I
was like thinking about it and grinding
on it thinking about it why would I
realize that a great question is a
question that's armed with knowledge
that's armed with care and thought and
that pierces into the gray matter of the
world in the universe that we live in
and looks for problems an inconsistency
and broken things great questions caused
us to sit for days and ponder a solution
great questions expose problems and
problems are the seeds to solutions
great questions expose roadblocks which
are an entrepreneur's opportunity a
great question sometimes will arrive at
an O which is the playground for a rebel
spirit and I have the great opportunity
in my life to work with a lot of
unbelievable entrepreneurs that are
solving extraordinary problems and the
one thing that they all have in common
is they all ask extraordinary questions
and they build their businesses from
these questions they build technology
from great questions questions that
parse apart existing businesses they
tear them down they tear down
conventions that we just assume are true
and they expose this magical thing that
exists behind every great business time
that most magical resource in the world
they find ways to save time I think time
exists on two vectors it exists on one
vector which is longevity it's a
vector that goes on and on and on and
we're always in our lives seeking longer
lives better lives it exists on another
vector which is quality we want better
lives lives that are more filled with
Wonder and enjoyment and entertainment
those are the two vectors of time and
those are the two vectors that every
single business every single great
business exposes and they expose it
through great questions you know I think
that if I could give young Hollywood a
suggestion it's to do something that I
never did which is have the courage to
stand up and say what you believe and be
responsible for your actions now
a big part of growing up in this
business which in a lot of ways I did
was you know you spend a lot of times
just trying to be liked and you get
really worried about do people like what
I did people appreciate my work and
because that is your paycheck and and I
think that having the guts to just be
yourself sometimes is harder than people
think
I believe that opportunity looks a lot
like hard work when I was 13 I had my
first job with my dad carrying shingles
up for the roof and then I got a job
washing dishes at a restaurant and then
I got a job in a grocery store deli and
then I got a job in a factory sweeping
cheerio dust off the ground and I've
never had a job in my life that I was
better than I was always just lucky to
have a job and every job I had was a
stepping stone to my next job and I
never quit my job until I had my next
job and so opportunities look a lot like
work but I took this like big risk and
quit school I quit the one thing that I
was like that was like surefire and went
and became a model and it got really
bored really fast and didn't love being
a coat hanger and then I became an actor
which was like a coat hanger that talks
and and then and then I ultimately like
came full loop it came back around and
and by the way when you talk you're
generally not even speaking your own
words you're speaking somebody else's
words and try to make it sound really
real and then I keep full loop around
and and and started looking at
technology again I started getting
interested in technology and started
getting interested in engineering and
started really getting interested in
solving problems solving my own problems
and then solving other people's problems
and what the value of that is as to
whether it's it's technology or
philanthropy or actually even performing
or being an actor I started to make it
about solving problems and I think that
that's the that probably the single
biggest thing
as an angel investor I look for in
entrepreneurs is people who genuinely
want to solve a problem a real problem a
problem that exists not just for
themselves but sometimes just for
themselves and then it and then it then
it sort of turned into this wave effect
that solves other people's problems and
sometimes by trying to solve your own
problems you're solving everybody else's
problems because generally if you want
to affect the world you have to change
yourself first everybody tries to go out
and change the world by changing other
people and other things but the real way
to do it is by changing yourself and
sometimes making those really
uncomfortable choices to go up against
everyone in your life that you look up
to and take that risk to go be a model
what is the most magnificent question
well I have a question that I like to
ask two people that I admire in the
world and when I run into someone in the
world that I admire and I get to run
into these people quite frequently I
like to ask this one question and that
is what's the best advice that you've
ever received to get you to where you
are and I get amazing answers and I ask
this through this question in a very
particular way I don't ask it when I'm
in crisis I don't ask it when I need
advice I ask it proactively because I
sometimes think that when you ask people
that question of what is the best advice
when you need advice you'll paint their
answer into your question and if you ask
them while you're in crisis and you
expose your crisis to them they'll give
you an answer that actually color it
that is completely colored by their own
experience in their own problem which
isn't always the best thing to do the
best thing to do is build up this
reservoir this library of extraordinary
advice that you can access anytime
you're in crisis and that's what I do
when I come up against the problem or an
obstacle or a roadblock I then go back
to my index of advice that I've received
from extraordinary people and I look at
it and and and usually the answer is
already in there so I thought last night
as I was not taking this opportunity for
granted I decided to reach out to some
folks that I thought you guys might know
and ask them what the best piece of
advice they've ever
he was so that I could share today so I
reach out to my my my fiance Neela and
that was an easy one right and she said
don't let your ego get in the way of
asking for help I just I to me that is
great advice and to me I can use that
advice all the time I reach out to
Taylor Swift I figured you know she's
like the top of the charts right now I
wonder if like she would actually even
answer my email she did which is amazing
for the person who's like maybe the most
busy person on the planet right now she
answered this email because she thought
it was important that I share something
with you and she said keep your hopes
high and your expectations low you're
not entitled to anything but there's
nothing that you can't earn I love that
one you're not entitled to anything but
there's nothing that you can't earn and
most importantly enthusiasm can protect
you from absolutely anything whoo that's
good that like when I watch her do
interviews now I understand a little bit
more about her because she's always has
that enthused oh that like bubble going
I'm like you're protecting yourself I
dig it I like it so I reached out to
Bradley Cooper he's got like one of the
number-one movies in America this
American sniper movie which i think is
fantastic uh and he said hey pal thanks
for asking uh you know often I thought
about this old cartoon commercial when I
was a kid that sent a message to be
yourself and just how vital that is to
growth and when I finally realized that
notions some 30 years after watching
those commercials in between Saturday
cartoons I found a true difference in my
daily life knowing that we all have
ourselves and all we have is ourselves
our uniqueness that is what we can use
to cultivate in order to create or do
whatever it is that we want to do in
this life just be yourself simple advice
but it's really good advice and I can
imagine that advice coming hand
in a moment of crisis so I reached out
to Chris Rock and he loved his advice
that's a hard one how about one people
that can't listen can't lead to one of
the keys to success is the ability to
listen to people that you know that you
are smarter than I read that I was like
oh man oh no the whole thesis of my
entire thing which is like there there
are no dumb questions but there are dumb
questions and maybe I just maybe I just
undermine myself with that piece of
advice and I do think that that's
important I do think that it's important
to listen to people that you know that
you're smarter than because you may not
be and then he signed it the CEO of
nothing I thought was pretty good and
then I reached out to Eric Schmidt it
was a friend of mine and he said always
return phone calls take the time if you
put good energy out it comes back
whenever possible say yes just life is
just who you travel with I thought that
was pretty killer I say and this list
goes on and on and on and what I found
is like most successful people always
have more than one piece of advice so
that's my question that's the question
that I like to ask and that's the
question that leads me to solutions and
leads me to roadblocks sometimes and
leads me to internal quandary which
leads me to be a better person
I think the sexiest thing in the entire
world is being really smart
and being thoughtful and being generous
everything else is crap I promise you
it's just trap that people try to sell
to you to make you feel like less so
don't buy it
be smart be thoughtful and be generous
I'd like to sit down with founders and I
like to work on removing friction from
process whatever it might be and
creating products that are intuitive and
one of the things that I get from
working in the creative space and being
an actor is really understanding feeling
and touch and art and you know it's an
art being able to being able to create
an impulse within a consumer to do
something is an art form I can probably
give you 10 or 20 examples of companies
that have really just taken software
that was archaic software that was
untouchable by consumers and actually
brought it down to a consumer level that
that is becoming the process to making
it to building a great software company
these days you can look at a company
like zenefits it's like there's always
been HR software that's been out there
in some way shape or form or you can
look at Robin Hood and there's always
been ways that you can interface and do
stock exchanges but making it something
that that the average consumer can
intuitively understand and touch and
play with and use and and have it be
beneficial in their life is about
understanding the intuition and and the
feeling of the consumer generosity has
to be at the core of anything and
everything we do some of the best advice
ever received is somebody once told me
that there's the difference between good
and bad it's very simple is it good for
you is it good for me and is it good for
the greater good if it doesn't fall into
those three categories it is bad is it
good for you is it good for me
and is it good for the greater good and
if our actions are oriented by actions
of generosity that are good for me and
good for you and good for the greater
good
we'll always be moving the boat forward
the boat that we're all in I think
ASSA tea is paramount Steve Jobs said
when you grow up you tend to get told
that the world is the way that it is and
that your life is to live your life
inside the world and try not to get in
too much trouble and maybe you get an
education and get a job and make some
money and have a family but life can be
a lot broader than that when you realize
one simple thing and that is that
everything around us that we call life
was made up by people that are no
smarter than you and you can build your
own things you can build your own life
that other people can live in so build a
life don't live one build one I see a
lot of entrepreneurs that come in and
they have a really great idea to solve
something and I start to talk to them I
start to find out who they are and what
they're about and and they stay and they
sort of jump from the problem that
they're solving to who they're going to
be or what they're gonna get by and I
it's like I have this like red flag in
my pocket that goes up and I'm like wow
that guy wants to Mark Zuckerberg that
guy wants to be Pincus that guy wants to
be Steve Jobs or that guy just is got
this idea he's like yeah the market cap
is this and it's this and we're going to
make this much money and it's going to
be a billion dollar company and then I
just I have this like switch in my head
that just starts to shut off really
slowly when I hear this because they're
jumping to the effect and if you want to
be a real entrepreneur you have to be
the cause you have to be the creator of
somebody else's new reality which is
which has it which eliminates time space
motion pain friction that's what
engineering is and that's I mean it was
like the first thing that I learned as
an engineering student was you know it
you know scientist you know look at
problems and they you know find out
about problems and engineers solve them
and it's the one thing that really
really
stuck with me and those guys that wanna
be Mark Zuckerberg or girls that want to
be the next big entrepreneur that not
not the next big but the one that
already exist if you want to be Mark
Zuckerberg the best you're ever going to
be a second place because Mark
Zuckerberg will always be a better Mark
Zuckerberg than you and if you're chase
is for a billion-dollar company you may
not make a dollar so I wanted to tell
the story about a guy named Carl Fisher
how many people here know who Carl
Fisher is a couple people it's
interesting only a couple people know
who this guy is and after you hear the
story you're gonna you're gonna wonder
wow how do I not know who this guy is
and it's in when I heard this story it's
it's what Mark Carl Fisher was one of
the greatest marketers in American
history as a young kid Carl Fischer
couldn't see very well his eyesight was
pretty poor and he would go to school
and he would sit in the back of the
class or he would sit in the front of
the classroom to see but he was still a
poor student it didn't do well the
teacher moved to the back of the class
right so when he was a young kid he quit
school because there was nothing really
there for him he couldn't even see the
damn blackboard so he was like yeah you
know [ __ ] it I'm out of here right he
bails so then Carl gets this idea and
he's like he's gonna sell candy on the
train right there's these candy boys and
they walk down the aisle with these
boxes and they sell candy and so Carl
gets this idea but Carl's no no ordinary
Carl Carl was an amazing marketer and so
what he does is he gets a t-shirt and on
the t-shirt he pins this print of a
naked lady and he has his schmuck smock
whatever you've got a Jewish ma it's
schmuck and Jewish Shabbat so I can say
schmuck he has a schmuck and he walks
down the aisle with his candy box and as
he passes these businessmen he goes like
this it keeps walking I'll be like hey
kid get back here
and hey Carl says ok I'll do you there
like what's a litt you know when you get
underneath there yeah I'll show you
what's underneath there just buy some
candy so now I'm a marketing tactic
right like I'm going to show you a
little bit of the juice and then I'm
going to shut it off and then once you
buy this thing I'm going to give you the
full product right as a Korell makes a
lot of money like cos doing it like
these guys really want to see naked
pictures we all know that you want women
on your platform early hot ones first
and then everybody comes Carl nudists
way back in the day so uh so he makes a
lot of money and then he gets this idea
he wants to sell bicycles right so Carl
Fischer he sees all these bicycles back
back not eight late 1800s this is all
these bicycles in Europe and he's
thinking you know this is going to
explode in the United States and so he
opens up a bicycle shop and nobody comes
nobody's buying bicycles so he goes and
he gets this guy they could fit he puts
a wire from one building to the next
building and he gets a guy that knows
how to like a tight rope on the bicycle
and people come in they're like wow this
is amazing
and he find some guy that can do a trick
on a bicycle and people start coming in
buying bicycles as we start to sell
these bicycles and sell these bicycles
and then and then the automobile starts
to boom and he's like wow this is the
future now you gotta remember Carl can't
see so well but he gets a car with all
his money and he loves it and he's
driving this car blind as a bat and he
loves the speed of this thing and the
agility in the control that he has and
so he opens up a car shop and he was
like the first he opened up basically
the first automotive dealership in the
world and so we start selling these cars
and selling these cars and making a lot
of money and a lot of money and it sells
his bike shop obviously in order to do
the down payment takes this bigger risk
with cars and of course people start
buying cars it's the first automobile
dealership in the United States and then
you then you start thinking of ourselves
like seeing all these people driving
cars and thinks someday these people are
going to want to drive these cars at
night and so he invents the headlight
and he sells the headlight and he makes
a lot of money and so now he's a
millionaire
back at like the turn of the century and
he's got all this money and and and he's
doing extremely well for himself and he
goes and he goes to like I think he was
like in Minneapolis and he's like trying
to sell cars and sell this headlight so
he hooks this car up to a hot-air
balloon
he's like flying over the city in
Minneapolis and and trying to sell these
cars and promote his brand promote what
he has and she's this girl down in the
crowd below young girl beautiful girl
and uses land the balloon I have to go
meet this girl so he meets the girl and
they fall in love and she's like you
know you've worked so hard you have all
this money why do you keep working like
what are you trying to do and curls like
you know I just see things he was blind
dapat blind as a bat but he had vision
and he's like I just see these things
and I have to make them happen she's
like well you should just really settle
down and have a family and dude he's
like yeah but I you know it's like this
is what I want to do he's like well then
I'm just gonna do one more thing and
then and then I'll stop and so he goes
to Indianapolis and and he has this idea
that these cup people love cars he's
obsessed with cars
he's like someday you know it's like I
think people will want to race these
cars they're already racing them so he's
gonna make this track and people are
gonna race these cars so he invents the
Indy 500 he builds the Brickyard and
people like Karl you're crazy nobody's
gonna watch cars go around in a circle
this is insane and he says not only will
they come and watch they'll pay a dollar
and so he starts to charge people he
invents the Indy 500 he invents the
Brickyard and the first race like six
people died right because people really
funny that guy just died guys slow it
down the two soon that's too soon okay
so anyway like six people died in the
first race right because it's the brick
and people are flying off and whatever
but and so it was a huge disaster but
then he stays at it and he stays at it
because he even though he failed he knew
that he could change they changed the
surface and people start to come and it
actually starts to grow and it builds
into the Indy 500 visit is his wife is
like okay
this is a debacle you know let's just
stop doing these things this go on
vacation so he takes him on vacation I
surround like 1910 they go down uh to
Florida which at the time was like this
you know there was a couple like little
resort II areas but it was kind of a
mosquito infested environment and but
they're they're in there on vacation he
sees this bridge but going out into the
distance and he's like what the hell is
that
the wife's a girl don't don't go just
just relax and he's like no III just
want to find out what's going on with
this thing right so he goes new hunts
down the guy and he finds out this guy's
trying to build the largest bridge in
the world
I Carl's like well what's on the other
side and the guys like well nothing is
just like a swamp area sorry
and so get Carl Carl says we'll take me
over there so they go over and he starts
looking around he's seizing surveying
the land he's like just like oh wait a
second and he sort of gets down on his
hands and knees it's like looking and
like drawing a little thing like I said
what are you doing is like I think we
get backfill all this and turn it into
like a giant resort place and and and
the guys like what if you want to do it
you can do it I'm not getting involved
and and he's like well yeah but you want
somebody you want people to come to your
roof or your bridge right because the
guy couldn't get money he's like I'll
help you finish the bridge I want I want
the land on the other side that guy's
like ok so he starts back the only
backfilling backfilling builds it up
builds up these giant casinos this is
whole thing it's Miami Beach he's
building Miami Beach right and he was a
car at Carl's otherwise known as like
mr. Miami because of this and he fills
it in he builds all these casinos and
this huge area there's all of it and
nobody comes and he's got this giant
infrastructure now casinos and stores
and houses in cut and nobody comes and
he's like oh man I got to do something
so he gets like an elephant right there
people in America had seen an elephant
but an elephant people will come see the
elephant rides tell him he goes to
Congress and petitions for a highway
from the north coming south they build
the Dixieland he had enough money at the
time where he could convince him to
build a Dixieland highway from all the
way north all the way down to Miami and
nobody comes and he's like this is a
nightmare
right he's like dumped everything he had
all the money from the headlight into
this thing and nobody comes and so he it
naps the president in the United States
and it takes the president United States
out into this place and gets photographs
of him there he's friends with him so
he's sort of kidnapped him it's a better
story if he actually kidnapped him but I
made that part up so he takes the
president United States these new
pictures of him out on this out in this
island and people start to come one by
one by one and it's the biggest land
boom in American history and their
people are literally setting up card
tables in their front lawn selling land
and it's going and it's going it's like
the internet right now it's just
happening and everybody's coming and
they're coming and they're coming
they're selling and the prices are going
up and Carl's making millions he makes a
hundred million dollars before 1920 and
then he gets a brilliant idea
Montauk Miami of the north and he dumps
it all in the Montauk everything he's
got goes into Montauk and he's building
it up his wife is furious by the way she
adopted a baby he didn't even know about
this old nightmare story Carl start
drinking a lot it builds up Montauk the
stock market crashes he loses everything
completely wiped out Carl Fischer died
in a trailer home outside of Miami and
about a week before he died somebody
took him up in a blimp and they took him
over Miami and he was able to see what
he had built but that's all he had he
didn't have a dime he didn't have a
penny hardly anyone would remember his
name but he gave that to all of those
people and he knew that no one could
ever take that away from him he could
never lose that
he might have he might not have been
able to see but he had the vision to
know that it wasn't about his name or
somebody remembering him it wasn't about
the billion dollars it was about
uncovering that which was concealed the
swampland the corners of the room the
way people can exchange the way people
can connect with each other
the way that a database can be built the
way it's about uncovering it so it's
about Airbnb changing the hotel industry
it's about disrupting markets boldly in
a way that you can leave that behind for
everybody else to have and share and
Karl Fischer knew that so you might not
remember his name but you use his
product every day you might have visited
his town and I and the only thing I can
impart upon young entrepreneurs is it's
not about being like somebody else it's
not about the billion dollars it's about
how you can affect other people's lives
enrich them improve them how you can
eliminate the space between people how
you can eliminate pain and friction and
how you can uncover that which one day
was just a big land of just a big
swampland
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kevin Lopez
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did actions say that really
resonated with you what was the most
important take-home point that you took
from this video leave it in the comments
I'm going to join in the discussion
thank you again for watching I believe
in you I hope you believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you soon
okay now I want you to tell me which one
you Cho PepsiCo yeah it's Davis mic hey
hey um think I may have found a project
for you more of an RD out Taff than
anything but it's actually project you
prove some time back you should look
into it so this is the Macintosh team
mm-hmm
Jesus nope it's just Steve that it's
really good to see you asleep they
lacked it's good to see that any players
over here mm-hmm
oh hi Steve Jobs what's your name
upper mm-hmm Burrell Smith Burrell Smith
Oh her sorry for the mess I was buncha
Jarrett's so it's okay I like
degenerates
yeah who's your project Lee uh Jef
Raskin I don't know where he is Jef
Raskin okay I'll tell them I'll be
taking over now um sorry taking over to
like the entire Macintosh project yeah
awesome
where's your design team yep team and
show me your credibility
well obviously ease-of-use is the big
feature here we're trying to develop a
simpler interface that's geared towards
the real layman end-user but we're kind
of struggling with the interface and to
be frank the results of being yeah once
again under the hood stare kick-ass
stuff 64 K Ram 256 bitmap display
motorola 6809 we're gonna run the 16,000
but dude that's Lisa's processor that's
correct
dude I care what the budget is
give me that processor done hey Steve
are you man presidents below yep you're
working on the Macintosh yeah good good
missing me fun
okay let's go back to what you were
saying before this thing is for the
everyman right that's our end user it's
the schoolteacher it's the garbage man
it's the kit and some grandma out in
Nebraska right so we need to make this
thing simple it's got a work light like
an appliance hey Jeff Steve Jobs is here
since um you weren't around some of the
project leads we're having a meeting
with Motorola why exactly are you here
I'm here to help build the Macintosh ah
I'm not sure that that's practical for
us we're actually trying to avoid this
project becoming another over bloated
disaster okay Jeff you got my attention
look Steve you didn't want to be
involved back when we started this thing
and that was fine by me
I just wanted you to cut the checks be
involved just don't turn Macintosh into
a measure of revenge for you everyone
knows about your fallout with team Lisa
so trust me when I say we're doing fine
okay Jeff let's get a couple things
straight
we don't do fine I don't accept things
the way that they are and we don't stop
innovating as your machine lacks power
in your little interface and it's
working I'm here to help with that now
I'm not trying to take back and dodge
away from you I want you on this team
but you can either get on board or you
go
okay and we got a lot of work to do so
let's get to it bill
you come with me okay um we're we going
recruiting do you know why people buy an
apple why do they buy an apple not the
editor because it's got bravado it's
social status no you know what it's even
more than that it's social currency
we've raised the bar and if we want to
stay there
we got a risk everything great artist
Dylan Picasso Newton they risk failure
and if we want to be great
we gotta risk it too everything is a
pressing issue if we want to make the
vision for Lisa a reality we got to put
in the hours and make something crazy
yeah but we have a hard date on this
software and I'm sorry but adding pretty
fonts is not gonna change that good bill
if you don't share our enthusiasm and
care for the vision of this company no
no no it's like I'm not understanding it
out what you try and get out wait you're
dumb what yeah what are you gonna be
getting fire me
no I already fired you why are you still
here
Steve he was our best program in the
division he's the best programmer that
doesn't care about our vision read hey
you're wondering why I'm going through
your stuff okay let's see
I needed uh to borrow your saw because I
need to chop down a tree because there's
something stuck in it an animal a rabbit
there's a rabbit stuck in a tree and I
want to return that rabbit to the wild
so it can lay its eggs
Celso rabid stop how the hell did a
rabbit get up a tree um Eric threw it up
there
Eric threw a rabbit up a tree
yeah he's a sadistic bastard
you know he hit a cow
they change lightbulbs must be a
nightmare
Adam oh yeah we're gonna cook
oh I can't do this could you please take
me back to her no no that's not the deal
the deal is that we're gonna walk around
and we're gonna look at the twinkly
lights and then why are you messing
everything up
some people do I'm odd they buy each
other flowers and they go to museums and
that you know me this stuff freaks me
out it's fake what's wrong with what
we're doing it's working we don't have
to fight we don't have thing I want to
fight yeah well I don't what are you
gonna do you're just thinking you're
never gonna feel anything how you can do
that I don't know figure it out
you're so messed up yeah I don't need
you to take care of me I take care of
myself that's what I do
why don't you go find some other girl
who's not gonna hurt you because I love
you
obvious I completely love you there oh
you're such wimps I am NOT well then be
with me okay you're gonna fight it yeah
so you're gonna fight you can't fight me
your miniature you're like a girl Rick
Moranis Oh you fight like a hamster okay
hey excuse me excuse me you can't do
that here okay I'm sorry
on your Island
I can't keep doing this
but you failed
I'm not going to see you watch them
I know
that makes sense
i watch the line
what come
and I will
you go
and the girl